Un hospital local está realizando una rifa
para colectar fondos.
El costo individual de participar en la rifa está dado por la siguiente expresión,
"5t" más 3 ó 5 por "t" más 3, donde "t" representa el número de boletos que la persona adquiere.
Evalúa la expresión cuando "t" es igual a 1,
"t" es igual a 8 y "t" es igual a 10.
Bien, consideremos primero cuando "t"...
cuando "t" es igual a 1, entonces esta expresión
de aquí resulta en...
y lo voy a poner del mismo color...
5 por "t" que es igual a 1, 5 por 1 más 3,
5 por 1 más 3 y sabemos que en el orden de
las operaciones se hace primero la multiplicación
antes de la suma, así es que 5 por 1 es igual a 5 más 3.
5 más 3 esto es claramente igual a 8.
Hagamos ahora cuando "t" es igual a 8.
Cuando "t" es igual a 8, esta expresión se
traduce en 5... y voy a usar el mismo color...
5 por 8... 5 por 8 más... uso el mismo verde... más 3.
Y esto va a ser igual, 5 por 8 es 40,
más 3 y esto es igual a 43.
Hagamos el último caso, cuando "t" igual a 10.
Y lo voy a hacer en azul...
lo voy a hacer en azul...
así que tenemos que "t" es igual a 10, por
lo que "5t" es 5 por 10, en lugar de la "t"
ponemos 10, 5 por 10 más 3... 5 por 10 más 3,
ese es un tono distinto de verde,
pero bueno, lo importante es la idea, 5 por 10 es 50
y a eso le tenemos que sumar 3 y eso es igual a 53.
Y así, hemos concluido.